pour ouvrir cette série sur la
psychologie je voudrais vous parler d'un
truc dont je ne suis pas tout à fait
mais content j'ai inventé une parabole
d'abord c'est quoi et parabole bon c
soit une figure géométrique soit une
sorte d'antenne soit un court récit sous
lequel se cache un enseignement comme je
ne suis ni géomètre ni ingénieur vous
l'avez compris c'est la troisième
définition qu'on va retenir jeudi
pas mécontent parce que je les soumises
à deux trois personnes de mon entourage
dont des psychologues et qu'elles l'ont
trouvé plutôt éclairantes
certaines ont même réussi par la suite à
l'appliquer donc à s'en servir au
quotidien
bien sûr ça ne dit rien de la validité
scientifique de l'hypothèse qui soutient
la parabole mais enfin même si j'ai osé
utiliser ici dans le titre de la vidéo
le terme de loi surtout pour faire chic
jeu là vous je ne prétends pas ici
présenté des preuves de ce niveau de
solidité
tout ceci est donc à prendre comme une
proposition vous en faites ce que vous
voulez cette parabole
je les appelais le chien et la voiture
vous allez comprendre pourquoi dans une
voiture vous venez d'emménager dans la
maison de vos rêves avec votre famille
pour aller au boulot vous avez acheté la
voiture de vos rêves
non soyons réalistes une voiture normale
sur votre trajet quotidien vous passez
devant les maisons du voisinage
quand vous arrivez à la hauteur de l'une
d'elles ça ne manque pas un chien se
précipitent jusqu'au portail et à voix
de toutes ses forces au passage de la
voiture et ce tous les matins si au bout
de quelques temps vous commencez à
sentir une forme d'usure qui se
développe en agacement et qu'un jour à
bout vous finissez par lâcher
[Musique]
vous êtes devenu le chien et il est
devenu la voiture comment ça et bien
quand on passe devant la maison
on fait notre vie on ne pense pas aux
chiens mais lui quand ils nous voient
arriver
il est concentré sur la voiture il nous
perçoit comme une menace potentielle et
veut nous dissuader de venir sur son
territoire que se passe-t-il pour qu'on
s'énerve le bruit est une forme
d'agression qui s'invite brutalement
dans notre expérience et rompt sa
tranquillité en plus au contraire de ce
qui se passe dans le champ visuel
il est plus difficile de faire
abstraction on ne peut pas fermer les
oreilles
c'est donc usant en un sens très simple
sa demande de faire un effort cérébrale
pour repousser l'assaut sa fatigue parce
que nous dépensons de l'énergie à gérer
l'agression sonore nous délaissons les
parties notre esprit dédiée à la prise
de distance à l'analyse des passionnés
on oublie alors que le chien fait tout
simplement son travail de chien on s'est
fait happer par le chien
on est en quelque sorte pris dans le
monde du chien dans sa perspective est
ce que ça marche dans d'autres
situations
oui bien sûr sinon cette parabole ne
servirait pas à grand chose en fait je
crois même que beaucoup d'interactions
peuvent être éclairées ainsi imaginer
que vous marchez tranquillement dans la
rue vous croisez un de ces vieux ivrogne
anglais qui envahissent nos villes et ça
ne manque pas il vous insulte on peut
alors imaginer plusieurs réactions
possibles
option 1 vous continuez votre route mais
n'en pensait pas moins
option 2 vous prenez la mouche et
défendez votre honneur option 3 vous le
prenez avec compassion et sérénité parce
que vous avez compris que ce torrent
d'insultés ne s'adresse pas à vous
personnellement
en fait c'est tombé sur vous parce que
vous passiez à ce moment là mais grosso
modo le vieil ivrogne anglais réglé sur
n'importe qui à votre place ok peut-être
pas lui c'est là trois attitudes bien
différente et on pourrait imaginer être
encore plus de voitures
ce serait tendre l'autre joue et aimer
le vieil ivrogne anglais dans toute sa
splendeur renom de votre quartier il se
peut que votre voisin fasse une fête et
que le bruit vous dérange ou qu'ils
gardent in ou phase des travaux et il se
peut que volume sonore égal l'expérience
de la nuisance varient
peut-être que c'est la fête qui vous
énervera le plus parce que vous n'avez
pas d'amis ou parce que vous devez vous
lever spécialement tôt le lendemain ou
au contraire peut-être que ça ne vous
dérangera pas tellement parce que vous
êtes insomniaques de toute façon vous ne
vous endormez jamais avant 5 heures
dans ce cas c'est sans doute le
motoculteur matinale qui vous rendra fou
en gâchant votre grasse matinée tout ça
variera donc en fonction de votre vie de
vos habitudes de votre caractère de
votre personnalité
or une personnalité ses multiples et
surtout c'est rarement cohérent sans
doute que si le bruit vient de chez vous
parce que vous avez embauché un
jardinier ou un artisan ou parce que
votre conjoint ou conjointe fait des
travaux il vous paraîtra beaucoup moins
gênant pourquoi pourquoi à volume égal
le bruit du voisin est il davantage
désagréable d'abord on pourrait dire
qu'on maîtrise moins le bruit du voisin
par exemple on ne sait pas combien de
temps cela va durer
et puis on ne connaît pas forcément la
raison du bruit
peut-être que nous sommes davantage
capables de tolérer un bruit dont on
trouve la cause légitime si l'on sait
que c'est pour réparer la plomberie
parce qu'il n'a plus d'eau courante ça
semblera moins désagréable que si c'est
pour se construire un aquarium arquin
par exemple ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est
qu'on ajoute une dimension symbolique
aux phénomènes sonores pure et parfois
cette dimension devient personnelle elle
nous touche profondément
en fait au bruit on ajoute l'insulté ou
à minima le manque de considération au
fond de soi notre inconscient rumine ce
voisin ne pense pas à moi ma personne
n'a pas été prise en compte et ça nous
agressent aussi à un niveau primaire
quelqu'un qui ne prend pas les autres
rencontres c'est quelqu'un de menaçant
pour le groupe pour la communauté
c'est un mauvais qu opérateur social
quand deux amis ou des collègues se
dispute ou s'adresse plus ou moins
violemment des reproches on aurait
intérêt à garder cet éclairage en tête
si quelqu'un crie ou s'énervent il ya de
bonnes chances qu'il ou elle soit chien
il ou elle en fait une affaire
personnelle
et c'est précisément cette dimension là
ce qui touche sa personne qui est
exprimé dans la colère c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la loi de
l'égocentrisme ordinaire
grosso modo les gens se préoccupent de
même avant tout autrui n'est jamais
finalement qu'un prétexte
la voiture est un moyen pour le chien
d'exprimer sa nature d'animal qui défend
son territoire et sans doute que les
insultes du vieil ivrogne sont une
manière pour lui de nous rappeler qu'il
existe garder cela en tête
ce serait se rappeler que nous sommes
très souvent un moyen pour l'autre est
rarement une fin en elle-même un moyen
de recevoir de l'attention de
l'affection du respect un moyen
d'exercer son pouvoir parfois aussi bien
sûr ce n'est pas très agréable
d'imaginer qu'autrui nous voient comme
un outil mais ça permet de mettre en
perspective
l'expérience de l'agression garder ça à
l'esprit
ça permet aussi de distinguer la gêne
pur de la gêne symbolique la gêne pur
c'est ce qu'il y a d'irréductibles le
mans désagréable dans le phénomène
par exemple on pourrait dire que c'est
l'intervention brutale de l'ivrogne et
la violence graphique des insultes qu'il
profère la chaîne symbolique
elle intervient quand on se sent
personnellement insulter quand on
ressent par exemple le sentiment
d'humiliation que ce soit par les
insultes d'un ivrogne ou par une phrase
perfide lancé par un collègue se sentir
humilié par leur regard d'autrui
par son jugement c'est oublier cette
tendance c'est croire que dans
l'insultent de l'ivrogne il y a
effectivement des informations qui nous
concerne alors qu'il serait tentant au
contraire d'affirmer que quand autrui
nos juges il en dit plus sur lui-même
que sur nous
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas
donner d'importance au jugement d'autrui
le jugement d'autrui a une importance
capitale
quand il s'agit d'évaluer ma valeur
sociale par exemple je ne peux pas
décider moi-même que je suis gentil
seuls les autres peuvent le dire
je dois donc faire attention au regard
que les autres portent sur ce que je
fais sur ce que je produis pour la
communauté
c'est seulement comme ça que je peux
m'assurer que je suis un bon qu
opérateur social
en revanche là où le regard d'autrui
père impertinence
c'est quand il prétend définir mon
identité en tant que personne ce
jugement-là risque de mettre
principalement que la projection de son
propre esprit son système de valeurs
ces croyances fondamentales sur le monde
tout ceci est déjà bien difficile à
appliquer dans les interactions sociales
mais il ya un domaine où c'est encore
plus compliqué et sans surprise c'est
soi-même
il est difficile de ne pas faire de sa
propre personne
une affaire personnelle d'une certaine
façon on peut même être égocentrique
vis-à-vis de soi-même et c'est un peu le
sens qu'on peut donner à la phrase super
connu de sartre je ne peux jamais
m'observait moi même sens que le regard
de l'autre ne fasse irruption dans ce
face-à-face impossible je reproduis
alors les jugement d'autrui dans mon
rapport à moi-même
en plus on passe son temps à juger sa
vie et à se juger soi même et pas
forcément de manière très juste mais le
plus embêtant c'est peut-être qu'on ne
le fait pas trop vite qu'on doit ou
devrait aux autres mais plutôt vis-à-vis
de ce qu'on se devrait à soi même de ce
qu'on attend de sa propre vie mettons
par exemple qu'on soit triste voilà bien
triste on peut être chien donc égoïste
en quelque sorte vis-à-vis de sa propre
tristesse au lieu de comprendre qu'on ne
choisit pas ses émotions
pas plus qu'on ne choisit le défilé des
voitures devant chez soi plutôt que de
regarder le passage de la tristesse
comme ce phénomène étrange et éphémère
comme l'expression de lois physiques
biologiques qui nous dépasse et suivre
leurs cours ont fait le chien et on
prend la tristesse personnellement on la
regarde comme un ennemi interne une
erreur quelque chose a refusé voir à
combattre pour conclure on pourrait dire
ceci prendre du recul et se détacher de
ses sentiments permet de voir plus clair
en eux et de comprendre que tout comme
les pensées ils ne sont immoraux numéro
ce sont des phénomènes naturels au même
titre que la flétrissure d'une feuille
d'arbre ou qu'une vague dans l'océan
en revanche ce sont donc nos actions qui
peuvent être moral ou immoral et c'est
de cela qu'il faut se préoccuper
cette parabole n'est pas une excuse pour
mettre le son à fond et penser que c'est
à votre voisin de ne pas faire le chien
rappelez vous il reste la gêne pure est
de ceux là
il peut se plaindre légitimement
rappelez-vous puisque ça peut être
pratique que distinguer la gêne pur de
la chaîne symbolique permet de réduire
les nuisances
pour finir de vraie citation authentique
cette fois
j'espère que ça vous a plu sinon
j'essaierais de faire mieux la prochaine
fois
salut